[Music]
on this sunday night
ontario reports its highest number of
covet 19 cases
ever the rise of the variants across
canada
the consequences are obviously pretty
dire why businesses refuse to listen
to the health experts we've had enough
of this outdoor spread
a new warning about the potent power of
the virus even outside
boosting singh's profile the ndp's
pre-election
strategy and repairing the royal rift
could the death of prince philip
bring harry back into the firm
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the race between vaccines and
variants is at a critical point
because this third wave of the pandemic
is coming on strong
the surge is largely driven by variants
of concern
particularly b117 which was first
detected in the united kingdom
health officials believe it is now the
dominant strain in most regions
including alberta
as of today more than half of all the
active cases in the province are
variants of concern
alberta has fewer restrictions than many
parts of canada but as heather york's
west explains
more and more albertans are defying what
public health orders
are in place on the first sunday since
rcmp
erected a barrier around the grace life
church outside edmonton
a crowd of hundreds gathered in protest
the church had been defying public
health orders for months
earlier in the day a convoy of
supporters set off from calgary
by midday the peaceful protest took a
turn when a small
number of people charged the barrier
tearing portions of the fence down
just one of several recent acts of
defiance against public health orders
on tuesday the alberta government
ordered an end to indoor dining
but by the weekend places in calgary
edmonton
and parts in between were refusing to
close their doors
i just don't see the reasoning for it
and if i close again i may never open
again
we've had enough of this it's not
sustainable we don't like where this is
going
we cannot survive
if we do another lockdown my staff
cannot survive the reality is variants
of concern
are fueling exponential growth in
alberta the b-117 variant is now
considered the dominant strain in the
province
while the even more highly transmissible
p1 variant
is spreading fast on friday calgary had
13 reported cases
by saturday that number had grown to 70.
restaurants
and churches they've all been associated
with large-scale transmission events
um that's the reality so you know it's
imperative that
that again those settings are mitigated
as much as possible alberta's premier
under pressure for more than a quarter
of his caucus to open the economy
further
has said that more restrictions could be
necessary if current measures don't turn
things around
speaking on saturday jason kenney urged
supporters of the grace life church
to take the virus seriously my message
to people of faith in particular
would be if you believe in the sanctity
of human life please
act accordingly but once again this
faith community remained defiant though
for the first time in months its service
was held
outdoors heather eurix west global news
calgary
nowhere is the situation more dire than
in ontario it is the epicenter of the
pandemic in this country and today
more troubling news the province
shattered its daily record for cases of
coven 19.
more than 4 400 new cases were reported
in ontario today
the most ever in a single day trying to
limit exposure to the virus has become a
tricky part of our everyday lives
no environment is 100 percent safe and
as catherine ward explains
one frontline doctor believes his
patient got sick from the virus
by being outside the risk of
transmission outdoors is very small
but not zero so it needs to be
considered that consideration played out
in an ontario hospital this week
critical care physician dr brooks follis
posted on twitter about a patient who
was diagnosed with covid19
after a backyard gathering the patient
told follis how he thought
outdoors is always safe you know virus
will clear rapidly but that doesn't mean
it was never there
so if you spend an extended period of
time in close proximity outdoors you
still are at risk of transmission
experts agree masks and physical
distancing add more layers of protection
but some doctors say they're worried
that by making examples of large crowds
at parks or stores
it could lead to unintentional
consequences
looking for is drivers of transmission
and being outdoors
is not something that's going to really
increase
hospitalizations down the road so i
worry that
by stigmatizing
outdoor gatherings that we're going to
we're going to force those gatherings
indoors and that and that would be the
worst case scenario
when it comes to what is allowed for
outdoor gatherings the rules differ
across the country in quebec in regions
where special emergency measures
apply private indoor and outdoor
gatherings are for the most part
prohibited
in ontario a province-wide stay-at-home
order remains in effect
outdoor gatherings are limited to five
people as long as
physical distancing is maintained and in
alberta
outdoor social gatherings are limited to
10 people with physical distancing
experts say one of the best things you
can do is have a plan
in place with people in your household
before heading outside
important to identify what your deal
breakers are before you're
outdoors in scenarios you might not
anticipate and knowing those dealing
breakers ahead of time make it very
easy for you to enter and exit
situations
to ensure that you can keep yourself
safe catherine board
global news toronto canada's most
popular ski resort whistler
is one of bc's coven 19 hot spots it
accounts for
22 of the province's cases involving the
p1 variant
now the bc government has launched a
mass immunization campaign for the
community
the vaccination pool has been opened up
to all adults living and working in
whistler
the resort was ordered closed at the end
of march after it was determined that
travelers from
other parts of the country brought cases
of the virus to the area
between january and april there were
over 1500 confirmed cases of covet 19
in the community the new democrats have
resoundingly endorsed their leader
jugmeet singh singh is at the center of
a multi-million dollar ad to boost the
fortunes of the party
it's part of the strategy to get ready
for the next election for the past three
days the party met for its national
convention
but as david aiken reports much of it
was bickering about how the liberals are
poaching
ndp ideas
new ads from jugmeat singh's ndp
part of a multi-million dollar ad buy on
tv stations in bc and ontario
aimed at boosting the party's fortunes
while taking a strip out of justin
trudeau's liberals
those are the messages we want people to
know we're on their side and the
liberals have shown again and again
that they've sided with the ultra
wealthy during the liberal convention
which ended saturday
liberals boasted about all they had done
to help canadians through the pandemic
singh on sunday at his convention
delivered a scathing attack on those
liberals saying
they would not have acted but for ndp
pressure in a minority parliament
you know what we've seen in this
pandemic is that the liberals like to
take
credit but new democrats like to get
results
we fight to get results new democrats
have long been frustrated that
liberals get credit for scooping
progressive ideas
first proposed by new democrats let's
say to those parties that like to
campaign as new democrats
get out of the way we're already here
for example liberals at their convention
voted to make national pharmacare and a
universal basic income
their top two policy priorities and yet
those two proposals have long been basic
ndp policy we've seen liberals do this
historically that's kind of the ongoing
problem that they they say one thing and
they don't
do it and with pharmacare what's really
striking is
this is a 23 24 year old promise that
they continue to break
singh also had some harsh words about
the conservatives today but
with his convention speech and with
those tv ads the ndp are making it
crystal clear that in this pre-election
season
the ndp you're taking dead aim at the
governing liberals
robin no surprise there david aiken in
ottawa thanks david
church services across the united
kingdom included tributes to the late
prince philip
the prayers highlighted his years of the
queen's side and the decades of service
to the commonwealth
philip lived a long life 99 years but
his children say that still didn't
prepare them for his death
our europe bureau chief crystal
goodmansing continues our coverage from
windsor tonight
loss is lost for each person
it is felt individually they are words
of comfort at a time when
hearts are heavy the archbishop of
canterbury is the most senior clergyman
of the church of england
the queen its supreme governor for the
royal family
as for every other no words
can reach into the depth of sorrow that
goes into bereavement
several members of the family attended a
service in windsor
pausing to reflect on the loss of prince
philip i feel very sorry
and supportive of my mother who's
feeling it i think probably more than
everybody else it's still a dreadful
shock
and we're still trying to come to terms
with that and it's
very very sad but i have to say that the
extraordinary tributes
and the memories that everybody has had
and been willing to share
has been so fantastic mourners continue
to leave flowers
cards and mementos near the gates of
windsor castle
prince phillips coffin rests inside the
castle's
private chapel on saturday it will be
moved a short distance
to saint george's chapel the funeral
will be the first
public appearance for prince harry
alongside his family
in more than a year last month harry and
his wife megan sat down for a very
candid interview with oprah winfrey
about what life was like inside the
royal family
harry acknowledged the strained
relationship he has with his father
and his brother a shared grief at the
present time because of the death of
their grandfather
i think is an ideal opportunity i hope
very much that it is possible to mend
any rifts that may exist prince philip's
passing
may unify the family princess anne
in a written tribute praised her
father's many qualities
saying my father has been my teacher my
supporter and
my critic but mostly it is his example
of a life
well-lived and service freely given that
i most want to emulate
adding we will miss him but he leaves a
legacy
which can inspire us all and crystal
keeping with tradition
charles now inherits something from his
father tell us about that
that's right when prince philip passed
away as air
prince charles received the title duke
of edinburgh but it is worth noting
that when prince charles becomes king
that title duke of edinburgh will be
passed down to the youngest
and it will be given to prince edward
robin all right thanks for that crystal
commencing
in windsor tonight we have sad news
tonight about the death of a veteran
canadian journalist
matthew fisher a foreign correspondent
has passed away
i've just emerged from 37 days in the
desert
fisher was a familiar face on global
news he spent 35 years filing stories
from around the world
covering conflicts including the wars in
iraq and afghanistan
as our own mike armstrong remembers him
maybe every profession has their giants
well this was one of ours he covered it
all
everywhere his family confirms he died
yesterday after a short battle with
liver disease
matthew fisher was 66. still ahead
hundreds of storms pummeled the american
south and more bad weather
is on the way plus cova 19 infections
are hitting the u.s
harder than canada
wow look at that millions of
americans are bracing for another blast
of wild weather
more than 350 severe storms have
battered the southern u.s since friday
there's major flooding in mississippi
where two tornadoes touched down
another ripped through a town in
louisiana killing at least two people
staying in the u.s a record number of
americans received their covet 19
shots but hospitalizations are rising
especially in the midwest
as jennifer johnson reports it's all
happening as the biden administration
promises to get to the bottom
of how the pandemic began in china are
you ready
the u.s hit a record high saturday
administering over four and a half
million cobit 19 vaccines in a single
day the good news
comes as new cases in at least 32 states
are rapidly rising
fueled by unvaccinated young people
infected by the b-117 variant
that originated in the uk it's more
transmissible
it's higher morbidity higher rate of
hospitalizations and causing a lot of
young adults to get sick
even though one in five americans are
fully vaccinated hospitalizations are
increasing
the midwest has been hit the hardest
michigan is now considered the nation's
new epicenter
second only to florida in cases of the
uk variant the governor is asking for
more vaccines
what's happening in michigan today could
be what's happening in other states
tomorrow and so it's on
all of us to recognize we can squash
where we're seeing hot spots
it's in everyone's best interest medical
experts are again telling people even
those vaccinated to take precautions
avoid large crowds and wear masks in
public but americans remain divided
including this defiant anti-mass crowd
in florida
saying they don't believe the centers
for disease control or trust the science
science is pivoting along with our
knowledge to be able to take care of
this
and the benefits of the vaccine
tremendously outweigh
any potential downside meanwhile the
biden administration is promising to get
to the bottom of what exactly happened
in china
that led to the start of this pandemic
we need to do that
precisely so we fully understand what
happened in order
to have the best shot possible
preventing it from happening again
lincoln
blaming china for a lack of transparency
when the outbreak began
which he says allowed the virus to
quickly spread throughout the world
jennifer johnson global news washington
still ahead a quebec man's warning about
the virus
after he nearly succumbed to it
a quebec man and his family endured a
terrifying experience
he was so sick with kova 19 that he
spent
months in hospital he almost didn't make
it now he's hoping his story can serve
as a warning amanda delawicki reports
well today's the reflex we'll hopefully
win a prize on a sunny and hot spring
morning peter scufaris enjoys the
company of his wife and daughter
he savors spending time with them
knowing just a few months ago
his life was in danger his body racked
by covid19
it's like a roulette in the casino you
could get
a very simple dose or you can get what i
got
and i never wish it on anybody last
christmas
65 year old peter contracted covid his
three children weren't worried
their dad was healthy and athletic but
within a few days
peter deteriorated struggling to breathe
it was like like lightning speed
the change admitted to the icu doctors
placed him on a ventilator and in a coma
while his body broke down it just
happened so quickly and it was
i think like the worst day of our life
he developed blood clots
double pneumonia and myriad other health
problems as he lay unconscious for
five weeks fighting for his life it
didn't look very good it was in
very bad conditions it was devastating
it was very difficult
it was quite unbelievable we didn't
really couldn't really grasp what was
happening
peter's family never gave up hope he
would recover
and slowly he did
nurses helped him walk again after
losing 40 pounds
in all peter spent almost three months
in hospital
doctors never able to explain why kovitt
attacked him so savagely
he has great lungs how is this happening
and they just said it was it was a big
viral load
when peter finally left the hospital
relieved icu staff clapped as he left
he now faces a long road to recovery
a true family man he believes the
support of his loved ones
helped him survive
i don't think
i could have went through it without
them
yes peter says he has much to look
forward to
i want to hug my kids and i want to hug
my grandkids
that's the first thing and you know of
course i would like to play a round of
golf
a remarkable tale of survival and a
reminder
just how dangerous covert can be amanda
delawaki
global news montreal
up next the path to the cosmos how one
canadian choreographed ballet
and science together
the volcano on the caribbean island of
saint vincent has erupted
again emergency officials can only
describe it as a battle zone
at one point the power was cut and water
is hard to come by
la sifliere first erupted on friday many
have been sleeping in emergency shelters
since residents are told to stay indoors
because of poor air quality
ash has completely covered the
surrounding villages
even barbados which is nearly 200
kilometers away is getting a whiff of it
scientists believe there will be more
eruptions for days or
even weeks when it comes to reaching for
the stars countries like the us and
russia
usually take the lead in space
exploration while canada
takes a back seat so what can canadians
do to put their mark on the cosmos
mike drewlay looks at the path to space
for the longest time shamira andres
thought her future was on the stage
dancing was her singular passion until
her high school class went to canada's
wonderland
to take measurements on a roller coaster
she eventually had a choice
between the top schools for dance or
science
today she's working as a young graduate
trainee at the european space agency
so you can deduce the patch she chose
but she now sees a connection between
her skills in ballet and science for me
i would really love to be a dancing
astronaut
if that is a profession that i can make
but for now i'm trying to find my
passion in planetary geophysics and
science communication and education
canadians who dream of space are limited
with what they can accomplish here at
home
the canadian space agency chooses our
future astronauts
but to take part in a mission to mars or
fly to the moon
the only option is to go elsewhere
montreal's farah alibay was interested
in the mars rover program
so she got a job with nasa in california
today she's part of a large team behind
the first attempt
to fly a helicopter on another planet
[Music]
canada does have a robust aerospace
industry but the majority of its focus
is on designing and manufacturing parts
for planes and helicopters
here on earth recalibrate the esc where
canada does excel is in education
mcgill professor inna scharf's research
into autonomous vehicles
and space debris attracts international
students who will likely leave canada
after they graduate i hope that they'll
come back eventually
i hope they'll start companies or come
and work for
for the companies that we have here
andres is currently working in the
netherlands and plans to go to france
for her phd
after that who knows she likes to say
there's no linear path to space
no matter where she goes she's certain
of one thing there will be canadians
along the way
oh my gosh i i think we build every each
other up together
honestly and even though we might not
know each other personally that
community in space is very very
inclusive
i feel that i found my people mike delay
global news toronto
you can watch and read more about this
story at globalnews.ca
the new reality and that is global
national for this sunday night i'm robin
gill
tonight your canada is agassi bc we
would love to see your corner of the
country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk and i'll
see you next weekend
have a great night
you